what's up you beautiful rejects just
wanted to let you all know that we are
coming to WonderCon Greg Coy and myself
live Sunday March the 26th 11 A.M to
noon come join us for a discussion about
the current state of the MCU and DCU
fandom should be a blast now let's just
jump into it how's it going citizens of
the reject Nation we are back for yet
another movie reaction first time
watching and with me in the hot seat
once again it's the ever unpredictable
Roxy strier how you doing Roxy when you
watch back this video you will see that
we opened with me trying to fist bump
you and you left me so hanging you just
wanted to hang out with the citizens of
rejection which I understand so
concerned with them but I was just like
this and so everybody at home all the
fist bumps
yeah there you go
we are here to watch Ip Man people don't
know much of anything about this movie
other than it is at least some iteration
of the story of the master who trained
Bruce Lee very excited to check this out
and as always before we hop into this do
all the regular things leave a like on
the video subscribe to the channel hit
the notification Bell and be sure to
follow Roxy on social media as well as
the world girls how are the world girls
doing we're whirling whirling and
twirling that's good for a martial arts
movie as always if you want to see The
Full Experience alongside us uh
everything that doesn't make the
reaction highlights come on over to
patreon.com real reject subscribe over
there sync up with your own copy cannot
show you the full movie unfortunately
but hey it's a fun time just the same as
well thank you to prepper for editing
down these highlights Roxy are you ready
to throw down the year the year is 2008.
I'm in high school it
it comes out
clearly not because it's 2023 now but
let's hop into this
foreign
[Music]
excited
[Applause]
martial arts got his whole own Street
yeah martial arts street okay
start practicing all on top of each
other
much be rather flying a kite than having
a fight
[Music]
yeah you just showed up out of nowhere
foreign
immediately starving
I know this looks so good I want
she might be the most stunning person
I've ever seen in my life
dude you've tried to play it down but
it's just live Your Truth All Right Live
Your Truth Roxanne
you can't catch something that's
unattached
yep
that fly back
you got the best seat in the house dude
oh
like he says here I come but he stays
still
[Music]
wow
that was very endearing actually though
yeah
I'm sorry
oh
it's okay buddy dust yourself off
oh he's gonna think that he told them
yeah
[Music]
oh hey I don't know kick his butt
um
yeah there you go go take it up with him
oh he probably thinks that Master EP
told this kid though
[Music]
um
foreign dang that's a debate yeah whoa
pick up pants
he I did not expect a pantsing no yeah
but Justin yes we know all cops are
Justice
oh a stare whoa
whoa
how do you do that
[Applause]
gun must not have been assembled that
well
sad I know yeah
yeah get out of your
heads up
[Music]
couldn't be too nice
foreign
I love her
this is a lovely Garden yeah
should we move in we can afford this
is
martial arts are taking over your life I
wouldn't say she threw a tantrum about
it I mean that was pretty hysterical all
right I don't know what you call it just
lose her mind check her into the
institution
oh good
another great set yeah
oh he knows
whoa no
ah
whoa that KIPP up down that was crazy oh
in his legs
oh
thump
how frequently does this happen on the
street I don't know this must happen all
the time but the guy did accept his
challenge you have to accept anybody's
challenge what are the rules
oh
so you get one of those and they don't I
mean it seem fair nah his dudes got that
big ass
damn the sound design too
oh
Punk
that was really good yeah that's some of
the best fighting I've ever seen in my
life
John
fella
it seems like such a sweet guy oh you're
just saying that because he's always
smiling
what does it mean to beat the master
though do you get to school or you just
embarrass them I think yeah it's mostly
just your your embarrassing them and
then their students are going to have
doubts about them
ah God you really feel those impacts man
no no no no no oh nice oh damn it how
are they doing this
please
oh no
they're all martial artists right like
this isn't stunned people I mean both
it's probably like a bunch of stunt
teams
job's not done
[Laughter]
can't eat until we've beaten the best it
feels like a musical a little bit I love
it like Kung Fu West sides yeah
oh shoot yeah
plenty of uh want ads he comes into his
home plenty of classifieds
kick this guy's ass honey I'm with her
don't break these things they're so nice
foreign
[Music]
what's your BET right now why you think
IP is going to lose and then go on some
kind of like massive Revenge but I feel
like if it's gonna beat this guy's ass
right now we just have quite some time
left in the movie but I can't picture
him losing
good
he's playing defense though oh yeah
don't break damn it man you had one job
the wife probably heard the crash and I
was like oh yeah
damn it
that's what I'm betting on I'm betting
that this whole place gets right ah
damn it kiddo
ORS
[Music]
this is the cutest oh dude now you've
done it
brat don't talk about the sun I don't
spend time with
wow
her work in this movie too is there a
word for people who hate kids
yeah can you be a Phyllis sanderist or
something or I don't know what sounds
those were that just came out of my
mouth right there but uh the actual word
is a mesopotist one who hates
children isn't it man great though let's
get back to it man
oh like a brick jeez
wow
[Music]
oh that's so unfair right no this is
regulation oh
nah this dude's desperate
this is so dope yes such a great touch
uh give him a spanking
foreign
[Music]
you see them
oh damn
oh no
and still it just kept trading is this
about to be a World War II movie
very well could be we got a couple more
years still
but this just said Japan invaded China
China invaded Japan
[Music]
wow
wow is this true I think this aspect
must be true
all right oh no
no
homeless and for solution wow
doesn't
mean
she is such a natural way about her yeah
[Music]
oh no
so you're gonna start up a school so
they can fight back
maybe maybe that's how they'll make a
living now
[Music]
oh what a contrast
yeah that was
like the contrast from the the first
part of the movie to now is almost like
parasite it's like a different genre
yeah whoa
and the feathers
yeah good catch what a different time
that's the least you can do after you
set you up foreign
no
don't [__] with my girl
is
gonna go work at that Mill right now
this got so sad so fast like life I
suppose
what
oh damn
is his name still carries weight yeah
well I'm a little surprised he accepted
despite all those other people in need
but yeah that did seem not in his
character but his wife needs it so yeah
just the color contrast with the food
oh
yeah
oh buddy
he's out chasing a kite somewhere that
was such a beautiful moment when he gave
him that
oh I was in the box I don't know is that
about to be a big problem seemed like it
now that the Japanese are here what a
moment that was though yeah
um
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
just keep on asking bud no one wants to
be a traitor he'll get it eventually
um
yes yes it is
foreign
[Music]
box though
oh
oh ho ho ho ho what is it for their
entertainment or something partially
probably
Gaga
but also yeah I guess probably to break
the faith that they could fight back at
all
okay okay
oh
yes you are just Gladiators then
this is so interesting
damn
still keep your pants in your belt so
it's not as dark as I thought it was
where they were like fighting to the
death or something
oh whoa
[Laughter]
color in this movie is fascinating yeah
because we are in a black and white
scene right now right full blown either
black or white or just like incredibly
desaturated yeah
oh
Jesus dude
these shots okay so maybe it is as dark
as I thought it was
oh
[Music]
wow
nope
he's gotta find that 10.
this has so much Poise yeah he's like a
true star yeah
[Laughter]
I do not like that guy yeah he's doing
he has to do to survive but he's a
traitor yeah bringing people where he
knows that they're getting so hurt did
his best not to bring up
but yeah
or learn how to do that yeah
[Music]
you gotta get up
to fight dirty
I just let him be done
what it's why
this is why you're not the head guy
yeah
was he I mean that's the strong
implication he didn't look like he was
going to walk away from that last fight
I mean that active Defiance spitting in
the General's face pretty much sealed it
you know
[Music]
I feel like he's gonna run the whole
line
yes
you do get to talk right now dude
yeah
you calm down you're lucky to be here
right now I hate him
oh damn
oh
wow wow
[Music]
oh
Christ
they're all coming at him one at a time
I know there we go yeah they were like
people are gonna start to wonder
[Music]
oh
we've never seen a fight like that
not with Fury
yeah yep yep
if he picks it up you're gonna shoot him
take the rice so you can give it to
people
hahaha
yep
no more this
we have a title
video
[Music]
because you are
good
next video
no you're not
everybody has to do
you crush him right now your dignity bro
I can't stand you you're the worst kind
of person
you are a traitor
ha ha
second means
yeah
clean yourself up for the potato I
understand I just have to wash your face
she seemed pretty clean to me
this guy I was hoping you'd make a
return yeah
oh
these dudes like marauding
oh that's a brother kite boy
there you go
I was cool even they came back so in the
truck was it a bunch of Japanese
soldiers I don't know if it was a
soldier truck but it seemed like it was
a Japanese truck okay yeah I think at
the moment I thought this was going to
be some kind of Robin Hood face turn for
them but uh no they're just robbing
folks from Foshan from folks from the
mill so uh you know there you go
Cinema
oh
yeah
oh damn you Northern guy rematch
I'll get there get there
yeah it's a necessity
the school right here
laughs
long last
come join Master IPS School of kung fu
oh
[Music]
my hands becoming a part of the
community training montage sequence
commence yeah
[Music]
even family life is better now foreign
dude
someone needs to desk this guy or
relieve him of Duty entirely
Teach Me How to Dougie
[Music]
oh no
no
why did she make noise just that I don't
know no no
no no no no no no no no no
oh yes yes this is gonna be bad for you
but yes they all have guns oh my gosh
yes hey guns don't mean [__] right now
yeah
foreign
[Music]
Rubino
Hong Kong
um
Asgard as a people oh this guy comes
back no you I mean you're either with us
or you're against us you got to team up
the enemy of your enemy is your friend
you need to be our friend right now you
cannot be causing this kind of ish
you're not helping you're not helping
anybody's cause
oh yeah
sharks in a jet stuff
yes let's go how much are you guys
foreign
okay this is the least realistic part
but I'm still really into it they all
learned how to fight like gangsters in a
day you know they're taking some hits
oh yup defend yourself oh
let's go let's do it but if you're
supposed to be in hiding honey it's okay
he can't stay hid when there's Injustice
afoot
I love it is the best character
no we didn't
you ruined this because
oh
and I've been hungry every day since
Jesus don't do it you're in fighting
none of you guys are the problem oh boy
let's go
sugar
come on dude
he's got the ultimate rage one and he
didn't know his brother's dead
I'm pretty good with the bow stuff
[Music]
nicely done and that must have been a
nice soft Landing
[Music]
do you think he ever opened it knowing
him probably not right probably not yeah
I would say it would respect the
integrity
oh no what is it it's the kite oh oh
it's his kite
oh
buddy
nah he's gonna go straight there
[Music]
'd be right because it's gonna protect
the people right yeah he's just gonna go
have it out once and for all
foreign
[Music]
nope
yeah dude let's go let's go
wow
so it's a guitar
oh
baby
no you didn't honey that was not a
tantrum
yes you did babe it was a different time
you did yeah so much yeah you both he
could have showed up for the kid more
before you need a little you couldn't
realize yeah it's okay you both have a
character arcade
come down
[Laughter]
all right what do you think it's gonna
lose
and everyone's just gonna be subject to
that much more tyranny don't say that
um
[Music]
well we got it we understand
foreign
wow
damn dude
nice use of Leverage
I am so invested right now yeah
breathless
oh I would so love it if you just got
knocked out of bounds and they were like
good the Japanese win yeah
yes yes
oh
don't shoot him come on don't shoot him
punch him
oh
oh no what she went there why why'd she
go
going right Back to Basics I feel like
they're gonna shoot him
[Music]
he saw the guy reaching for his gun
surrender
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no I'm nervous no no
no no
oh
damn it
this
guy someone needs to smack the [__] out
of that guy
that's a pretty high wound you can get
the best singing that but
yep that's all we needed
kill him come on dude
yep come on
[Music]
yeah
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Music]
oh God this is not a good way to save
somebody's life yeah you're gonna crush
him is anybody a doctor
foreign
[Music]
oh no way my man all right okay all
right okay okay wow
[Music]
oh wow
strange question mark hey you sure about
that subtitles yeah
I could see why you want to learn from
him
that was truly unbelievable God what a
movie so what do you make of how much of
that do you think is true real I was
just wondering that yeah I have I mean
the timeline and the history aspect of
it feels very real I'm curious about the
actual Ip Man of it all yeah me too
because I've heard you know in hearing
about this movie over the years people
have often gone out of their way to be
like yeah it's the story of Bruce Lee's
Master like you know it's it's
embellished a lot uh but yeah it's it's
based on that true story and and here
watching this this felt more grounded
and more historical than I was expecting
like I came in expecting a lot of crazy
ass fights and stuff like that and the
fights are amazing but like I expected
almost every fight just from hearing
about it over the years to be like yeah
10 people at a time like that one uh and
it's not exactly that so I would be
fascinated to see and I don't have the
best you know historical knowledge of
this period this conflict Etc this part
of the world but uh that's the that's
the part that's crazy because it says
you know August 1945 so obviously we
know that I obviously World War II is
near and dear to my heart as my family
comes from Eastern Europe and is Jewish
so but I think about it on that front I
am so ignorant when it comes to
um I know more a little bit about the
Japanese front but not with regards to
China yeah absolutely you can kind of
look like look watching this and knowing
the dates and no having a little bit of
an understanding of the world but being
like what happened there yeah that is
actually a big blind spot for me
um you know we think about Japan in
regards to the United States we don't
think about Japan in regards to
um wherever in China that you know they
said from 300 000 people to 70 000
people and it's like what I don't even
know that story yeah absolutely and then
it makes me wonder then I'm like okay so
what was our relation to China then
during all of this because again in
America you you have Pearl Harbor you
have all those right with Japan yeah you
have the very Vivid Japanese American
conflict right but what was our yeah
relation to China during the time if any
at all really yeah you think enemy of
your enemy is your friend but also I
think more we were fighting on the
Eastern European front sure yeah just
that's a big blind spot so it was it
almost made it more enticing of a movie
because I genuinely was like what is
that what's gonna happen here yeah 100
like I really enjoyed that that historic
it's it's weird because it does put you
I feel like oftentimes when you figure
out like okay this is a true story this
is based on history so you feel like it
won't like I feel like in in some cases
that will ground you and make you sort
of less expecting of the unexpected
whereas here I was like man this is like
a situation I I knew this is expanding
my pre-existing knowledge on World War
II and just the time leading up to World
War II and things like that like I was
completely unaware that it man was I
guess at this point do we call it this
is a World War II movie right yeah I
mean it's historical fiction I mean it
encompasses it takes place during that
time yeah that time and then up until
you know slightly I mean you know the
epilogue gives you the information as to
what happened slightly after but
but yeah this is a highly skilled
fighter sets out to defend his people
amid simmering tensions and brutal
conditions in China under Japanese
Occupation so I I just knew of this as a
fighting movie I knew of this as like an
action-packed but the whole historical
relevance of it was really just next
level elevated it but then completely
apart from that the the story is so
beautiful yeah the story of him and his
family the story of him helping his
people the story of even when you have
nothing giving everything you have to
your loved ones I loved that yeah and
like I I really loved how grounded a lot
of this was because again I went in
expecting something a little more
mystical a little more stylized whereas
this felt like it was just as dedicated
to living in the time and place that it
was depicting and living in just the
people's lives of the day and I loved
how it took you from you know and and
you know like in fitting with movie
structure you take us from the status
quo like everything's great everything's
at least you know you have this conflict
with this guy from the north coming into
town trying to prove himself but you see
the status quo of just what flourishing
life is like uh in what is it called
Foshan and then you know watching then
the huge contrast descend as you know
the Japanese invade uh yeah I just made
everything like way more tangible and
way more affecting than I was expecting
and so it it made me want to go out and
like learn more about the history but I
also just found myself appreciating yeah
like like we were both pointing out you
were especially were pointing out like
the set designs are beautiful it's so
well crafted and realized and caringly
recreated you know yeah so incredible
and I'm with you I did think that this
was almost gonna be more like just
bigger and more Fantastical kind of and
it in some moments it is there are some
moments where it's like you know uh just
so wild like everybody in the street or
like we're all coming to your house and
we're coming inside and it feels like I
said at times it feels like a musical
like a West Side Story but really it's
hard at its core it was so grounded
which is kind of bizarre not what I was
expecting from this and it does make me
want to go do more research which you
know is a sign of a good movie when
you're immediately like I've got to
start googling because I need no to know
more about Ip Man I need to know more
about this time period in this location
uh yeah and the infighting part was so
interesting that they that they have
that in this where it's not just the
Japanese Occupation of this area of
China it is the uh it is Chinese people
and Chinese people fighting with each
other because they don't want to be
bullied like as they said that and if
that obviously resonates with this
country right now I forget which
stand-up comedian I was talking uh not
talking to I was listening to the other
day it might have been in Chris Rock
special where he was talking about you
know half the people right now if Russia
came here half the people would be like
let's hear them out because we there's
so much infighting in the United States
where we're not even on the same page
and it's like you would like to think
everybody joins together in a time of
War but in this time of War I thought
what was going to happen is that once we
the the Japanese Occupation comes we
both thought like oh they're coming back
and they're coming to help and they're
not coming to help they're coming to
harm and it's like whoa that is
realistic but also gut-wrenching yeah
you came back and then you came for your
own people oh that was uh great the
theatrical choice but brutal yeah and I
wonder how that moment would play if if
you are familiar with both Japanese and
China because when he comes into the
into the road there and he stops the
truck I think yeah it creates this idea
of like oh man he's about to throw a
wrench in their system but you know you
you see at least one brief shot of the
people in the truck and you're like does
this look like two regular people though
I wonder and then yeah yeah and and it
goes by quick enough that you're still
just sort of charged up like that's the
thing is this movie has the emotional
impact that makes you like charged up
like it has the emotional experience
that I think I was expecting going in
but yeah with like way more grounded and
interesting circumstances so that yeah
when he comes back to town with the
brother it is like a greater part and
it's a part of the conflict that I'm
glad they touched upon because I feel
like in any culture this is liable to
happen you'll have your people who are
under the thumb of the Tyranny you'll
have your people who are trying to fight
back in some way and then you'll have
your people on the margins who are doing
their own program trying to scavenge and
survive and you know really every man
for themselving basically and then
there's people who go into those
classifications at a different time like
we saw with Trader yeah Trader was at
first in one of those genres and then
was like or in one of those groups and
then was like I cannot betray my people
like this even if it kills me and I
can't really delude myself into thinking
that I'm somehow helping to ease
tensions between us I'm a translator I'm
a translator you're still helping their
operation more than you're helping you
know yeah until he wasn't that was so
every character served a purpose too
like the the nephew and the son the wife
um the guy that borrowed money from him
the brother and the guy with the kite
and his brother just there were so many
characters that I cared about and we
wanted to see what ended up at the
trader uh the general of the Japanese
Army's right hand man who we hated who
was even a bigger villain than the
general himself because you couldn't
trust him there's just so many people in
this that I was like I am curious what
happens with you your character is so
developed in my mind even though they
might not have spent that much time with
you yeah I am shocked with how much I
love this yeah and it unfolds in a
really natural way that doesn't feel
overly contrived like part of me again
they get to the whole Like Gladiator you
know they're they're all barred up and
they're going on to the mat and fighting
for rice and I was like part way through
like okay so here's where all the the
shit's gonna go down but no not not even
really like we check out of there for a
good long time and and we just feel yeah
the time and the geography and the life
of the situation and I love the way that
yeah you you just like I it's one of
those movies where the pacing feels so
natural that you're never really
thinking of the mechanics of what the
pace is doing and why certain moments
are where so it creates this really
natural blossoming from or I guess
wilting out of yeah you know the again
status quo of life and and seeing Ip Man
as he was then so poised always gentle
and smiling you know certainly willing
to you know engage in a duel or whatever
but a guy who is not initiating yeah and
then seeing how that adjusts itself how
that Poise adjusts to the descent into
the Tyranny and and seeing how he still
has so many of those same you know core
tenets of his character even though
they're slightly different because of
the circumstances he is still kind of
giving off that same impression it's so
much about how he carries himself and
holds himself and that creates this
really great Mystique around him in a
way even though he does just feel like
I'm like a man and then everybody else
around him feels that much more human as
a result and and like I think it's good
that the movie
it's like it would have been more of a
movie choice to have that one right-hand
man you know I wanted to see him get his
ass beat you know at the end after after
shooting him and all that stuff uh but
it's not exactly that kind of movie and
that's okay you know yeah you know that
the First Act or however long that was
where we just from the start of the
movie to the point where he beats the
bot of the guy who uh comes in to start
his own School in his house yeah I had
turned to you and I said what do you
think's gonna happen here because I
thought that was the villain of the
movie yeah it was gonna be the whole
movie you know so I'm like okay so maybe
they have to draw or he has to lose
because we got to fight this guy again
at some point thinking that that's the
whole movie and had that been the movie
had that been the theme of the movie had
we not had all any of the other
developments yeah doing schools in the
streets and who gets to have the schools
there and what matters in terms of can
you still have a teacher who who isn't
the most powerful can they still teach
whatever I thought that that's kind of
the themes we're going with and I was
thinking to myself okay I'm down for
this ride yeah like it wasn't like I was
sitting there thinking oh I'm bored this
is whatever but then the movie decided
to be so much more than that it decided
to then be like oh you thought you knew
what this movie is you don't you don't
know what life is because you know
what's around the corner an occupation
yeah that you can't like action movie
hero your way out of you did not see
this coming because nobody sees War
coming like this like exactly and it
just it hit both of us we kind of turned
to each other and we're like
[__] just got real yeah really real yeah
and the colors changed and the
atmosphere changed the prop everything
just looked so different as it would
during wartime and then I turned to you
he said what was the year on that just
thinking like
oh my God we're we're in on in this
planet yeah like this is we're in
history yeah yeah we're in history yeah
that was just such a great job of I
don't think that they were trying to
trick us but of starting with one thing
that would have been a good movie solid
but then turning it into a great movie
by being like this there's so much more
going on here yeah that's the fun part
about watching something like this a
little after a lot of people and and not
coming in having seen like a trailer and
all sorts of other stuff is yeah you
have a couple Notions of what you might
expect you probably know Donnie Yen and
then yeah it really this was you know
what I love so much about various
cinematic experiences and especially
ones like this and I love too that like
I have more experience when it comes to
you know historical operatic Chinese
Cinema stuff you know like like your
obvious things like a Crouching Tiger or
hero or House of Flying Daggers or
something like that and this has
less of the Fantastical operatic side of
that but it does have that you know
traditional history mixed with just
dramatic Cinema like it it has all the
action it is an action movie but it
really feels like a historical drama
that just so happens to center around
people who practice and communicate via
in certain situations the martial arts
yeah I would say that the strongest part
of this film is the story Idaho isn't it
isn't that crazy like you would think
that when we were seeing the costume
design and everything I'm sitting there
thinking of course the strongest part is
going to be the martial arts and then
it's going to be the design of it all
but the strongest part to me and this is
no knock on anything else no is the
story yeah no it's like it's a it's like
in the best way possible that's an
awesome surprise because if the story is
good that only makes the action that
much better and that only makes it more
of a complete and well-rounded film and
and even other things like I love being
able to sit through a movie like this
and be like wow like what interesting
choices of the color grading and you
know the way they've chosen to frame
certain things and it's like it's got a
lot of very lovely and and striking and
deliberate imagery throughout and harsh
imagery especially throughout
um but really harsh and the flashes of
some really harsh imagery yeah and like
the way they draw those contrasts and
the way they highlight you know it's
like it man you could argue like you
know he is so poised and in so many
situations you're like well he's he's
got this
but it's all the other intonation of of
emotion that they put both on his
character through the visual
storytelling but also just through the
greater tapestry of all the other
characters around that really create
something that feels
still rich and emotionally alive you
know even though yeah I mean he is it's
about him kind of learning his place it
feels like in this greater than life
conflict and learning how to apply
skills yeah his value his skills and
yeah the value like the True Values and
tenets of what the martial artist for
and how he might be able to yeah Inspire
and empower the people around him not
just as a teacher for the clout of a
school like we see at the beginning but
like for the the real reason these Arts
exist it's like you know you gotta
imagine they always say like you know
you learn this stuff for defense you
don't want to have to use it whereas you
know he finds a situation in which no
these people need this yeah yeah the
lesson in that also being that it
teaches you principles that you apply in
life such as in life you do what you
have to do so as he turns to his wife
and says I haven't had to work now I do
so I'm gonna do that and and the
humility that it takes to know that you
went from being this Rich well-known in
your town respected guy to shoveling
coal and he doesn't seem to have any
judgment on that situation that's
negative he just knows in life I I don't
want to fight I don't I'm not looking to
fight I don't want to have to shovel
coal but you have to do what you have to
do based on the cards that you're dealt
and therefore I'm going to do that so he
is able to apply those lessons outside
of martial arts and then teach other
people to apply those lessons which is
really cool and then the other thing
that I will say about this that I
thought was interesting and I know that
I get knocked on this all of the time
from my friends my family and from
people on the internet which I
completely get because it makes me sound
so ignorant is that I have a hard time
with foreign language films because I am
partially dyslexic and it takes me a
really long time to read things and so
oftentimes I go dubs not Subs which I
know people I know
when I tell people that it honestly they
treat me like I I murdered their
firstborn like they they people hate
that and I get it it is a character flaw
and I and I understand why because as an
artist it is uh disrespectful at times
to not be able to pay attention to the
the original art and um I really do try
recently I'm really trying to train
myself you know if you have to pause you
have to pause whatever but I was so
invested in this story that I really
forgot that I was reading yeah it was
like just going there it was not over
dialogue heavy which was helpful uh it
was more in like their the facial
expressions and the moments and whatever
but for me somebody who does struggle
foreign language films it to love it to
this extent is even just more credit to
this movie that it was like just it was
a cakewalk in terms of the subtitles
that was that I hope that it doesn't
deter anybody because it was so well
done yeah absolutely it it yeah it like
the the there's good uh you know I'd say
it's a well-written movie there's good
dialogue throughout but it is one of
those movies that's also very well
visually told so yeah it's like there
isn't a lot of laborious dialogue that
you gotta really keep up with to
understand like an exposition stuff can
get really hard when it's yeah like
remember last Tuesday when you called my
uncle and I'm like I've lost the this
yeah yeah give me little alert chunks
please sure sure and this is the perfect
blend of of yeah like there is context
and there is certainly you know certain
stuff that you can only get out via
dialogue but there's so much of this
that is so very Universal and clear
through yeah just bolstered by those
visuals
and bolstered by just the emotional
again the subtle emotionality of the
filmmaking on display in general because
yeah if they can get you to that place
where you're not even thinking about it
that's that's the ideal and they really
did they really did I was able to turn
that nervous part of my brain off like
am I going to be able to keep up and
really just enjoy the ride yeah that was
so good so good and I it makes me wonder
like how on Earth do you turn this into
a franchise see if there's that two and
three I think there's it man four I
think there's a lot of it man's so I'm
like they must at some point like Ascend
into a certain level of fantasy or or
you know I don't know being good do we
know I think it's a well-liked series
overall I mean I think I I don't my
guess from the outside is I would be
surprised if they are able to maintain
all of the
um you know coalescing genres that make
this movie what it is right I I I guess
me I would expect for the sequels to
increasingly lean into the Mystique and
you know the crazier and crazier fights
and things like that but I don't know I
I don't like you see the epilogue you
know and they tell you sort of the the
wrap-up history of how he goes on to
start his school and then you know train
all these people and that has to be
truly right yeah and I mean like that's
my main Association up until now was
like oh it's it's Loosely based on the
guy who who trained and inspired Bruce
Lee
um so so having that in mind you like I
feel like there's plenty of room for
them to to get bigger in terms of
fantasy but yeah just thinking about
those moments I was like so are they
gonna did they leave anything out that
will lend themselves to a sequel story
because it seems like he just kind of
went on and lived his life and opened
his school and realized that new aspect
of the dream in Hong Kong Etc
um yeah everything else feels like it's
probably not as grounded in the truth
yeah so I'm gonna go off with the
character and yeah they didn't know how
big the franchise was gonna be is it man
too just gonna tell the story of you
know it's the 60s and he's running a
school like I don't know yeah I'm not
sure about that either it is rated R are
you surprised by that or because of the
violence you think that that makes sense
I'm not surprised it's not the hardest R
I've ever seen but it is one I think
that deliberately uses the harshness of
again wartime and at least a there are
enough really pointed blood gags and and
you know like when that one guy gets
shot
in the you know sparring Dojo like
that's pretty harsh the bloody rice yeah
so it's one of those things where I
wasn't thinking at all about the rating
but I'm not surprised it's rated R uh
because yeah yeah I mean it's getting
into pretty harsh territory and there is
just like
you know people can hit a lot a lot a
lot a lot and even though it's not the
bloodiest movie ever you know you've
seen bones breaking you're seeing a fair
amount of blood when it's appropriate so
yeah I I feel I feel the r on this and I
feel like that substantiates some of
that historical drama too you know what
this is gonna end up being like a movie
that I tell people if have you not seen
this you have to go watch it you know I
can just tell immediately while I was
watching it in my head I was thinking I
got to tell my friends yeah and I'm sure
most of them yeah it came out over a
decade ago I've seen it rocks but this
is one of those things where I feel late
to the party and I need to make sure
that nobody else is misses the party
yeah no 100 it's one of those movies
where it's I have that same inclination
I'm like oh I gotta go talk about this
as many people as possible or tell
people to see it and it's so cool
because again like it's not John Wick
and I love a John Wick movie I'm excited
for Donnie Anne to be in John Wick 4 but
like this is like such a film and it is
so again it has all that badass you know
fist pump being stuff that you want and
but it's not as Fantastical even as like
a Crouching Tiger and yet it's not just
that fist pump movie either like it's
it's kind of a nice niche for this uh
kind of Cinema to me where I feel like
you know if you've seen a lot of the
biggest crossover hits that have come to
America but you haven't seen this this
might you know fill in a part of the
spectrum for you as it did me in a fun
way yeah I'm so with you that one scene
where they come to him and his wife is
standing over in the the gun with the
kid that's so chilling and that guy's
pointing like a real gun on his child
like that's what the R-rated kind of
stuff but that is that was such a crazy
scene and also just so when he as he had
been questioning is my martial arts
worth it like that do I have any value
you just protected and saved the lives
of your kid and your wife you have more
value than anybody could possibly have
you know like you saw what was gonna
happen there it was not about clout or
anything like that like I did love you
know again it gives you so many threads
to to think it'll follow and yeah at the
beginning with that other master and I
was like oh here we go you know
um but even seeing the way that that
evolved and letting every character
really feel like an alive actual
character you see that guy later on and
he's holding his own he tries to fight
three guys and it doesn't go well but
he's holding his own yeah you know like
there's so many nice little living
earmarks and elements they threw in his
like yeah this is fantastic that's so
good so good when we open it's all the
flags and I was thinking that's a lot of
flags but I didn't wasn't thinking it's
because they're about to be replaced as
they're going to be occupied you know
like they have so much
um nationalism and so much uh like pride
in their country and then when you just
see how built up and how how sort of
bustling and it at least seems very
flourishing at the top where where it's
you know it's right it's in the 30s but
it still has that kind of
not cyberpunk but you know like you're
used to cutting to like a city in China
or Japan it's like Signs On signs on
signs on advertisements and like there
is that kind of flourishing Cultural
Center uh quality and the amazing food
and we're seeing like all about their
culture in their in their um homes and
their food and their businesses and
their flags and their every in their um
the martial arts like it's it was so
true to their culture and then and to
the spirit of martial arts in general
yeah yeah yeah and then to be have that
taken over in such a short period of
time we I felt like I knew how
um I I knew how these people lived and
then it was like now you don't live like
this anymore well yeah and then and then
yeah it's like barbed wire and and you
know like big Japanese you know kanji
characters painted up all over the place
and it's just it feels like it's been
completely transformed in such a harsh
way and and and yeah it's like the movie
I feel like overall does like a really
cool job of embodying the spirit of and
the reasoning behind martial arts like
that debate that it man kind of faces
throughout about how and why to use it
and going from these scenarios where
it's like ah it's kind of fun you know
it's like for the clout of these
different schools and then going to you
know like really finding the true the
core the deepest reason to you know to
take a stand and to act
it's really beautiful yeah I'm so with
you wow yep yep a plus a plus that was
like a 9.5 out of 10 for me absolutely
not gonna go full 10. honestly I'm
trying to think what could have made it
better and I don't I I genuinely don't
know I just don't know if I've ever said
anything as a 10. that was as good as
movies gets for me if that one guy had
an extended sequence where they just
like beat the [__] out of him then it
would have been totally totally yeah all
right all right you got any stray
thoughts before we hit the road I guess
it's time to see it man too it man two
let us know in the comments if you want
to see it man too if you want to see any
other uh badass and or super affecting
martial arts joints you might want to
see us check out you know
comment below like subscribe all that
good stuff follow Roxy stryer follow the
world girls and last but not least let's
do a patreon
Chris Wham off Chris you are the IP man
of the patreon yeah no Chris is great
Chris is always poised Chris is always
out there helping the people but never
asking for too much he doesn't want to
be in people's debt and he doesn't even
care to have people indebted to him but
he's always out there helping out wham
bam thank you man if man wham bam thank
you it bam yeah there you go you should
create your own martial arts style
though that's what I would want to see
if you had to tussle if you had to throw
Hands Chris what would your approach be
what would be your Technique I want to
know something leaning in with the
pinkies yeah even the pinky can be Kung
Fu like uh like everything everywhere
yeah yeah that's good I like it well
Chris be well uh maintain your pledge
that's all we ask here uh otherwise
we'll come over there we'll jump you for
Honor yeah exactly JK never pick fight
with Chris I never pick a fight with
Chris because even if you physically win
morally he will defeat you 12 times over
we saw that happen in it man we did
that's why you are the IP man of the
patreon be well my dude
foreign